One, two, a one, two, three, four. Give me a break, give me a break, break me off a piece of that Kit Kat bar. Give me a break. Give me a break. Break me off a piece of that Kit Kat. Give me a break. Give me a break. Break me off a piece of that Kit Kat bar.
一、二，一、二、三、四。休息一下，休息一下，分我一块奇巧巧克力棒。休息一下。休息一下。分我一块奇巧巧克力。休息一下。休息一下。分我一块奇巧巧克力棒。
Have a break. Have a Kit Kat. Hi everyone. It's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded during APA's technology, mind, and society conference. held in October 2019 in Washington, D.C. I was on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Kim Mills was a guest host.
休息一下，来块奇巧。大家好，我是“心理学之声”的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。这期节目是在美国心理学协会（APA）于2019年10月在华盛顿特区举办的技术、心灵与社会会议期间录制的。当时我在休产假，所以我的同事金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）担任了客座主持人。
We hope you enjoy this episode. Hello, and welcome to speaking of psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the breadth and depth of psychological science. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Do you ever get the feeling at work that you're being watched? To a certain degree you are, and it's possible that you will soon be tracked
希望大家喜欢这期节目。你好，欢迎收听“心理学之声”，这是一档由美国心理学协会制作的每两周一期的播客，探索心理学科学的广度与深度。我是主持人金·米尔斯。你在工作中是否经常有一种被监视的感觉？从某种程度上讲，你确实被监视了，而且你可能很快就会被雇主追踪
even more closely by your employer, whether that's through video surveillance, GPS location tracking, or internet monitoring. If that disturbs you, you're not alone. Our guest today has been doing research into how much workplace surveillance is acceptable to employees and at what point do people feel that the nosy boss has gone too far? David Tomcheck is a product solutions consultant at Aeon, a global professional services firm. He is also working toward his Ph.D. in Industrial Organizational Psychology at the George Washington University, where he has researched the research,
更密切地监控，无论是通过视频监控、GPS定位追踪还是互联网监控。如果这让你感到不安，你并不孤单。我们今天的嘉宾一直在研究员工对多少职场监控是可以接受的，以及人们在什么情况下会觉得好管闲事的Boss太过分了？大卫·汤姆切克（David Tomcheck）是怡安（Aon）全球专业服务公司的一名产品解决方案顾问。他还正在乔治华盛顿大学攻读工业与组织心理学博士学位，在那里他研究了相关研究，
influence of electronic performance monitoring on employee behaviors. His interests also include personal environment fit, occupational health psychology, and corporate social responsibility. Welcome, David Tomcheck. Thank you. Glad to be here. So why do our bosses want to track what we're doing all day? I mean, Americans have a reputation for high productivity, which presumably means that we work pretty hard. Is that not right? I would definitely agree that we do work hard. I think in terms of what we have going on in the current sphere of big data, we have a lot of technologies out there that are capable of gathering large amounts of employee behavioral data in relatively short periods of time and relatively easily. To add on to that, we have artificial intelligence, algorithms, and machine learning that can kind of wrangle these big sets of data and perhaps give us some meaningful implications about employee behavior. whether or not that actually is indicative of employee performance is sometimes subject to
电子绩效监控对员工行为的影响。他的兴趣还包括个人与环境的契合度、职业健康心理学以及企业社会责任。欢迎大卫·汤姆切克。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。那么，为什么我们的老板想要追踪我们整天在做什么呢？我的意思是，美国人以高生产率而闻名，这大概意味着我们工作相当努力。难道不是这样吗？我绝对同意我们工作很努力。我认为就我们在当前大数据领域所拥有的而言，我们有很多技术能够相对较快且相对容易地收集大量的员工行为数据。除此之外，我们还有人工智能、算法和机器学习，它们可以处理这些大型数据集，并也许能为我们提供关于员工行为的有意义的启示。这是否真的能说明员工的表现有时会受到
criticism. But I think what employers want to do right now is to make the best use of all of that data they have and use that to inform productivity and performance or even guide safety or health behaviors. So what are employers interested in learning through these tactics? Are there motivations beneficent for the most part? Or do we even know? That's the big question. So what we find is that a lot of organizations don't actually tell employees that they're being monitored. And they don't tell them exactly, and if they are being monitored, they don't tell them when, how, or in what context they are being monitored. I think what a lot of organizations are hoping is that there are some sort of small employee behaviors that can sort of give some sort of credence to other aspects of job performance that we've traditionally,
批评。但我认为雇主现在想做的是充分利用他们拥有的所有数据，并用这些数据来指导生产力和绩效，甚至指导安全或健康行为。那么，雇主通过这些策略有兴趣了解什么呢？他们的动机在很大程度上是仁慈的吗？还是我们甚至不知道？这是一个大问题。所以我们发现，很多组织其实并没有告诉员工他们正在被监控。他们没有确切地告诉他们，即使他们被监控，也没有告诉他们何时、如何或在什么上下文中被监控。我认为很多组织所希望的是，有一些小的员工行为可以为我们传统上面对的其他工作绩效方面提供某种信誉，
try to capture just by performance appraisal. So for example, we have some organizations that are looking at facial expressions, voice intonation, and meetings, seeing how frequently people talk up or talk over other individuals. And a lot of that can be good. We can tell somebody after a meeting and say, hey, judging from our sociometric badge that we had on you, it seems like you're talking over individuals quite a bit. You're not giving your followers enough opportunity to chime in with any sort of creative problem solving that they have. So in that circumstance, we can get very minute aspects of job performance saying these are the specific situations in which perhaps you could work on something instead of maybe saving all of that for the end of
试图仅仅通过绩效评估来捕捉。例如，有些组织正在观察会议中的面部表情、语音语调，看看人们说话的频率或打断别人的频率。这其中有很多是好的。我们可以在会后告诉某人，嘿，根据我们戴在你身上的社会测量徽章来看，看起来你插话相当多。你没有给你的追随者足够的机会来提出他们拥有的任何创造性问题解决方式。所以在这种情况下，我们可以了解工作绩效的非常微小的方面，说明这些是你可能可以改进某些事情的具体情况，而不是把所有这些都留到最后
the year performance appraisal where some of those small behaviors might go overlooked. So a lot of what we're looking at is, is there meaning from very small aspects of behavior and how can that inform job performance. That's got me going down two trails here. One is, first of all, you mentioned biometric badges. But can you explain that? And, I mean, are they happening already? Are people wearing these things?
年的绩效评估，其中一些小行为可能会被忽视。因此，我们研究的很大一部分是，非常小的行为方面是否有意义，以及这如何能指导工作绩效。这让我的思路沿着两条轨迹展开。一是，首先，你提到了生物识别徽章。但你能解释一下吗？我的意思是，这些已经在发生了吗？人们在戴这些东西吗？
So they call these sociometric. Sorry, sociometric. So this is something that was started, I believe, in 2015 by MIT. They were looking at sociometric badges and looking to see how often we could get such rich forms of data intra-individual. So lots of performance or behavioral data within the individual. And what they're supposed to do is an individual wears this badge perhaps around their neck with a lanyard. And this badge is just continually taking in any sort of audio information that they have within a meeting. I don't think that this is used widely right now. But if you think
所以他们称这些为社会测量的。抱歉，社会测量的。所以这是我相信在2015年由麻省理工学院开始的一项研究。他们正在研究社会测量徽章，并希望看看我们能以多高的频率获得这种丰富的个体内部数据。因此，个体内有大量的绩效或行为数据。它们的作用是个人可能通过挂绳将这个徽章戴在脖子上。这个徽章只是不断地接收他们在会议中的任何音频信息。我认为现在这并没有被广泛使用。但如果你认为
about where certain technologies are going nowadays, where a lot of of them have these sorts of capabilities. When we think about all the things that your smartphone can do, the modern iPhone has facial recognition, it has a very good microphone, it tracks all of your internet behaviors. What we have right now are technologies that are going to be capable of kind of taking in a lot of this information. I don't think it's used very often now, but certainly there is some research indicating that it is trending towards that direction. So the other path my mind was going down when you started talking about this was, I mean, you know, I've worked in many offices and there are people who talk over other people. I mean, we all kind of know that, you know, Joe over there is a jerk in meetings. So is this just giving the employer some kind of coverage to be able to say, I have data that proves that you're a jerk in meetings? Yeah. So I think a lot of people have a resistance to criticism, especially anything that's negative. And, And when you can actually show them the data and say, hey, 60% of the time that you're talking,
关于某些技术目前的走向，其中许多技术都具备这种功能。当我们想到智能手机可以做的所有事情时，现代iPhone具有面部识别功能，它有一个非常好的麦克风，它可以追踪你所有的互联网行为。我们现在拥有的是能够吸收大量此类信息的技术。我认为现在不经常使用，但当然有一些研究表明它正朝着这个方向发展。所以当我开始听到你谈论这个时，我的脑海中浮现的另一条路是，我的意思是，你知道，我在许多办公室工作过，有些人会打断别人。我的意思是，我们都知道，你知道，那边的乔在会议上是个混蛋。所以这只是给雇主某种掩护，让他们能够说，我有数据证明你在会议上是个混蛋吗？是的。所以我想很多人对批评都有抵触情绪，尤其是任何消极的事情。而且，当你可以实际向他们展示数据并说，嘿，你说话的时间里有60%，
you're talking over somebody, or you have just repeated their idea and sort of steamrolled that individual, people might be more willing to accept that when there's actual evidence to support the fact that perhaps they're behaving incorrectly. But again, these are technologies that are not used extensively at this point, but they are kind of burgeoning. So the kinds of places that are using it now, are we just talking about tech companies? Is this like a Silicon Valley thing? Yeah, yeah.
你在打断别人，或者你只是重复了他们的想法并有点排挤了那个人，当有实际证据支持他们可能表现不当的事实时，人们可能更愿意接受这一点。但同样，这些是在这一点上没有广泛使用的技术，但它们正在蓬勃发展。那么现在正在使用它的地方，我们只是在谈论科技公司吗？这就像硅谷的事情吗？对，对。
So it would be very, very small usage in very tech-friendly companies, yes. So your research looked at the limits in the minds of employees. And what did you find? How much spying, if you will, is too much? Yes. So what we wanted to look at with our research was essentially where do expectations of monitoring come from? We have a lot of research saying that monitoring is an invasion of private, It's considered not fair to employees, but we're kind of curious about how that differs based on the individual or the job that they're in or the context of the organization.
所以它将在非常非常亲科技的公司中非常小规模地使用，是的。因此，你的研究着眼于员工心中的极限。你发现了什么？如果你愿意的话，多少间谍活动才算太多？是的。所以我们想通过研究基本上探讨的是，监控的期望来自哪里？我们有很多研究表明监控是对隐私的侵犯，它被认为对员工不公平，但我们很好奇这如何根据个人、他们所从事的工作或组织的背景而有所不同。
So we looked at our research from the psychological contract literature, which basically states that individuals have these unstated expectations of their employer. They basically expect their employer to treat them with respect, and they expect that their employer trust them enough to do the job. And so what we wanted to see is, okay, if you're being monitored in every possible way, let's say the amount of EPM increases. So, EPM is electronic performance monitoring. So perhaps you have your computer activity monitored, your emails being read, there's audio video surveillance. As that amount of EPM increases, we wanted to basically say, okay, it's going to be a violation
因此，我们从心理契约文献中审视了我们的研究，该文献基本上指出，个人对雇主有这些未说明的期望。他们基本上期望雇主尊重他们，并且他们期望雇主足够信任他们来完成工作。所以我们想要看到的是，好吧，如果你在所有可能的方式下都被监控，假设EPM的数量增加。所以，EPM是电子绩效监控。所以也许你的计算机活动受到监控，你的电子邮件被阅读，有音视频监控。随着EPM数量的增加，我们基本上想说，好吧，这将是一种违反
of the psychological contract. And this might lead individuals to behave in a way that is actually contradictory to what EPM tries to do. What EPM tries to do is direct people towards certain behaviors. When we monitor something, we are basically giving a signal to the employee saying that this matters. What we find, though, is that as the level of monitoring increases, the likelihood that a person experiences that as a psychological contract violation increases and actually leads them to withhold effort from the organization. So we're getting the exact opposite of what EPM is trying to do. We have people who might look at this violation and say,
心理契约。这可能会导致个人的行为实际上与EPM试图做的事情相矛盾。EPM试图做的是引导人们走向某些行为。当我们监控某事时，我们基本上是在向员工发出信号，表明这很重要。然而，我们发现，随着监控水平的提高，一个人经历心理契约违背的可能性也会增加，并实际上导致他们对组织保留精力。所以我们得到的完全与EPM试图做的事情相反。我们有些人可能会看到这种违规行为并说，
okay, well, I'm going to take longer on my breaks. I might show up late. And they do this in very covert ways rather than overt. They do ways that, because, of course, they are being monitored. Their actions are being monitored, and they don't have the ability to, you know, steal from the organization or anything like that. So perhaps they steal time from the organization. So what are the differences among job types or industries?
好吧，那我休息时间要拉长一点。我可能会迟到。他们以非常隐蔽而不是公开的方式这样做。他们这样做是因为，当然，他们正在被监控。他们的行为受到监控，他们没有能力，你知道，从组织偷窃或类似的事情。所以也许他们从组织那里偷时间。那么工作类型或行业之间有什么区别呢？
You're looking at that as well? Yes, so we looked at that from two different angles. We looked at first from the job attitudes angle, which would be job autonomy. This is the perception that an individual has over the discretion that they have over maybe scheduling their work, how they go about a certain task, and so forth. So what we found was that when EPM and the person, perception of job autonomy match, that's when we have the least amount of psychological contract violation. So basically what that's saying is that individuals who have high perceptions of job
你也在看那个吗？是的，所以我们从两个不同的角度来看待这个问题。我们首先从工作态度的角度来看，即工作自主权。这是个人对他们在安排工作、如何完成某个任务等方面所拥有的自由裁量权的看法。所以我们发现的是，当EPM与个人的工作自主权感知相匹配时，我们的心理契约违背量是最小的。所以基本上这说明，对工作有高度感知的人
autonomy, the belief that they can do their work as they wish, when that is coupled with low EPM, so these individuals are not being monitored heavily, they are the least likely to report any sort of psychological contract violation. Now, that effect strongly increases when you increase the number of monitoring and limit that person's ability to do their job. And interestingly enough, when people have low perceptions of autonomy, EPM does not appear to have any sort of effect. Those people are just as likely to perceive violation as, you know, a high autonomy individual
自主权，即他们可以随心所欲地完成工作的信念，当这与低EPM相结合时，这些个人没有受到严格监控，他们最不可能报告任何形式的心理契约违背。现在，当你增加监控数量并限制该人做好工作的能力时，这种效应会大大增加。有趣的是，当人们对自主权的感知较低时，EPM似乎没有任何影响。这些人同样有可能察觉到违规，就像（你知道的）高自主权个人
in a high EPM situation. So what rights do employees have in the workplace right now in terms of what can and can't be monitored? Are there legal limits or is this all just sort of a brave new world? It's an interesting time right now because of the general data protection regulations from the EU. So if we look at it just from the U.S., employees do not have a lot of rights. The privacy laws have not been updated since 1980. with the exception of, I think California has recently had some sort of privacy updates to their laws. But again, 1984, that doesn't really give us a lot of leeway in terms of what's going on with how people are being monitored now.
在高EPM情况下。那么目前员工在工作场所有什么权利，什么可以监控，什么不能监控？是否有法律限制，还是这只是一种勇敢的新世界？现在是一个有趣的时期，因为欧盟有通用数据保护条例。因此，如果我们仅从美国来看，员工并没有很多权利。隐私法自1980年以来就没有更新过。除了我认为加利福尼亚州最近对他们的法律进行了一些隐私更新之外。但同样，1984年，在人们现在被监控的方式方面，这并没有给我们留下太多的回旋余地。
The thing is that a lot of organizations are becoming global or international, and so they actually have to adopt GDPR rules. So what we'll be seeing soon is that organizations will be. be taking this a lot more seriously or at least address monitoring up front. But right now, employees in the United States, considering if it's just an American company, do not have many rights. There's actually no law that says that they need to be informed when they are being monitored, which is a huge problem, especially from the literature side. And is that happening in the companies that are doing it right now? Are they revealing to employees? Let's say when you go to human resources,
问题是很多组织正在变得全球化或国际化，因此他们实际上必须采用GDPR规则。所以我们很快就会看到的是，组织将更加认真地对待这一点，或者至少预先解决监控问题。但目前，美国的员工，考虑到如果它只是一家美国公司，并没有很多权利。实际上没有法律规定他们在被监控时必须被告知，这是一个巨大的问题，特别是从文献方面来看。现在正在这样做的公司里正在发生这种情况吗？他们向员工透露了吗？比方说，当你去人力资源部门时，
accepted the job and they give you all the paperwork that you have to fill out. Is there a form that says, oh, and by the way, we're going to be monitoring you. We're not only watching whether you're shopping on Amazon all day, but we also want to know what your skin conductance is and we're tracking your eye movements or whatever they might be looking at. Yeah, I believe there's a statistic out there that says about 20% of organizations actually fully inform their employees about when, where, and how they're being monitored. So this does not really happen very often. I can say from my experience, working for various organizations, I've never had that conversation, but I think right now we can just kind of assume a lot of, everything is being
接受了这份工作，他们给你所有必须填写的纸质文件。有没有一份表格说，哦，顺便说一句，我们要监控你。我们不仅在观察你是否整天在亚马逊上购物，我们还想知道你的皮肤电导率是多少，我们在追踪你的眼球运动或者他们可能在看什么。是的，我相信有一个统计数据表明，大约20%的组织真正全面告知他们的员工何时、何地以及如何被监控。所以这实际上并不经常发生。我可以根据我的经验说，为各种组织工作，我从来没有过那种对话，但我认为现在我们只能假设很多事情，一切都在
monitored. We have records of everything, every single mouse click, any sort of action that you do on your computer is recorded and can be accessed at any time. So I think some people will, regardless just sort of operate under I am being monitored. I just expect it. And our research actually supports that, that a lot of individuals say that I just expect to be monitored nowadays. I don't have to be told. I know that things are being recorded and can be accessed later. Are there differences among age cohorts? I'm thinking just millennials, I mean, people who are digital natives who kind of grew up in this world, that they seem to be less protective of their personal privacy than, say, baby boomers. Are you finding that in terms of being watched on the job?
监控中。我们拥有所有记录，每一次鼠标点击，你在计算机上所做的任何操作都被记录下来，并且可以随时访问。所以我认为有些人会无论如何都在我正在被监控的假设下运作。我只是期待它。我们的研究实际上支持这一点，许多人说我 nowadays 只是期望被监控。我不需要被告知。我知道事情正在被记录并且以后可以访问。不同年龄段之间有差异吗？我在想千禧一代，我的意思是，在这个世界中长大的数字原住民，他们似乎比婴儿潮一代更不保护自己的个人隐私。你在职场被监视方面发现了这一点吗？
We haven't actually explored age effects, but there has been some research out there that has kind of showed, in a comical way, how much young people are willing to give up some of their personal information for very small things. For one example, they found that college students were very willing to give up personal information for a free slice of pizza. So I think that there will be some differences. I think there's a generation of people growing up that have constantly had access to a phone that records their conversations. And I think they're getting very used to it. But I don't have any research to support that. Maybe something we'll look into in the future. So are people looking at the right things at this point? I mean, I'm thinking,
我们实际上还没有探讨年龄效应，但有一些研究以滑稽的方式展示了年轻人愿意为非常小的事情放弃多少个人信息。举个例子，他们发现大学生非常愿意为了免费的一片比萨饼而放弃个人信息。所以我认为会有一些差异。我认为有一代人成长起来，他们一直在使用可以记录他们对话的手机。我想他们已经习惯了。但我没有任何研究支持这一点。也许这是我们将来会研究的事情。那么人们现在在看正确的事情吗？我的意思是在想，
I believe where I work, they've implemented something that sort of looks at your calendar and maybe your keystrokes. I'm not sure what they're looking at. And they kind of tell you whether you had a day where you were sort of relaxed compared to other days. But does that matter? I mean, maybe I was super productive because I was off thinking really hard and I wasn't touching my computer much that day. But how can you tell? Right.
我相信在我工作的地方，他们实现了一些东西，可以查看你的日历和你的按键。我不确定他们在看什么。他们会告诉你你是否有一天与其他人相比有点放松。但这重要吗？我的意思是，也许我超级富有成效，因为我在深入思考，那天我没有怎么碰我的电脑。但你怎么能分辨出来？对。
So that is a question of whether or not what is being monitored actually means anything. I think this is the big problem right now is that because we have access to the data, we must try to find some sort of meaning from it. But like you just illustrated, performance or, how people go about their job-related behaviors is a very complex thing. Just because I can see that you're free doesn't mean that you're not doing anything. It doesn't mean that you might be less stressed. You could have personal aspects of work that are coming into play as well. And so I think organizations are getting closer to monitoring the right things for the right reasons, as long as it's
所以这是一个关于被监控的内容是否真的有什么意义的问题。我认为目前最大的问题是，因为我们可以访问数据，我们必须试图从中找到某种意义。但就像你刚刚说明的那样，表现或者人们如何进行与工作相关的行为是一件非常复杂的事情。仅仅因为我可以看到你有空并不意味着你什么都没做。这并不意味着你的压力可能会减轻。你可能也有工作中的个人因素在起作用。因此，我认为组织正在接近为了正确的理由监控正确的事情，只要它是
job-related and it's not looking at your personal activity on your personal smartphone or anything like that. I think these can be meaningful sources of data, but we just have to be very careful and very deliberate with how they're used. So are they looking at our smartphones now? I mean, you know, my boss certainly has my cell phone number. I think the whole world has my cell phone number. So who else is watching me? And what are they looking for? So we typically talk about this in terms of like company issued devices. So there was a case a couple years ago where an employee was required to download an app that would help her with keeping track of clients, but it sort of took location information at the same time. And what this amounted to is the fact that her employer could see
与工作相关的，它不会查看你个人智能手机上的个人活动或类似的东西。我认为这些可以是意味深长的数据来源，但我们必须非常小心，并且在使用它们时非常深思熟虑。那么他们现在在看我们的智能手机吗？我的意思是，你知道，我的老板肯定有我的手机号码。我想全世界都有我的手机号码。那还有谁在看着我？他们在找什么？所以我们通常在公司发放的设备的意义上谈论这个。几年前发生过这样一个案例，一名员工被要求下载一个应用程序，该应用程序可以帮助她跟踪客户，但它同时获取了位置信息。这相当于她的雇主可以看到
how fast she was driving on the highway at any given point. And so those are the sorts of things where it's unintentional with monitoring, but that can leave the employee feeling extremely violated or invaded of their privacy. When it's not used, used for its intention, that's when we find employee reactions to monitoring to be the most negative. So what are the next things that you're looking at? So we want to continue looking at where expectations of monitoring occur and what are the conditions under which monitoring might be accepted. So we can think of monitoring somebody's sweat levels or biometric levels as something that's very invasive. And I think you'd have
她在高速公路上的任何特定时刻开得有多快。这就是那些非故意的监控，但会让员工对自己的隐私感到极度被侵犯或入侵。当它没有被用于它的意图时，这就是我们发现员工对监控的反应最为消极的时候。那么你接下来在看什么？所以我们希望继续研究监控期望在何处发生，以及可能接受监控的条件是什么。我们可以将监控某人的汗液水平或生物特征水平视为非常侵入性的事情。我想你会有
very few people who'd be willing to give that information to their employer. But what are the circumstances where that's not the case? If I'm monitoring your sweat levels and able to give you a text at 3 o'clock saying you've sweat a ridiculous amount on your construction job, you need to drink some water before you pass out. Now, the purpose right there is very job-related. It's very employee-focused. It's safety. It's health. And so that might be a condition where something, when we just think of it, it might be invasive, but might be acceptable in one situation versus the next. So that's something that we really want to look at. We've expanded our checklist of how all the ways that people can be monitored to incorporate some of these newer things
很少有人愿意将这些信息提供给他们的雇主。但什么情况下不是这样呢？如果我监测你的汗液水平，并能够在3点钟给你发短信，说你在建筑工地上流了惊人的汗水，你在昏倒之前需要喝点水。现在，那里的目的与工作非常相关。它是以员工为中心的。它是安全的。它是健康的。所以这可能是一个条件，当我们想到它时，它可能是侵入性的，但在一种情况下可能是可以接受的，而在另一种情况下则不然。所以这真的是我们想要研究的东西。我们扩展了人们如何被监控的所有方法的清单，以纳入其中一些更新的东西
like biometric or facial recognition and are looking through qualitative data to understand, you know, if somebody thinks that this is sometimes acceptable, what are those circumstances? Great. Well, that's all really interesting. I appreciate your coming here today and talking to us about the research that you're performing and look forward to learning more about whether my boss is watching me or not. I'm going to certainly be a lot more vigilant. Before we go, I just want to give everyone a reminder that we want to hear from you. So email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. And please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. That's really helpful for us. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other informative podcasts, such as APA Journal's Dialogue about New Psychological Research and Progress Notes about the Practice of Psychology. You can find all our podcasts on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.spokenof Psychology.org and listen to more episodes. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
像生物识别或面部识别一样，并通过定性数据来了解，你知道，如果有人认为这有时是可以接受的，这些情况是什么？太棒了。好吧，这真的很有趣。我很感谢你今天来到这里跟我们谈论你正在进行的研究，并期待更多地了解我的老板是否在监视我。我肯定会变得更有警惕性。在我们走之前，我只想提醒大家，我们希望听到您的意见。所以请将您的意见和想法通过电子邮件发送到 speaking of psychology at APA.org. 请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分。这对我们真的很有帮助。“心理学之声”是 APA 播客网络的一部分，其中包含其他内容丰富的播客，例如 APA 期刊关于新心理学研究的对话以及关于心理学实践的进度说明。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 www.spokenof Psychology.org 并收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击成绩单中的任何句子发表评论。